hello believe nation I started the
mentor me series to try to spend a
little bit more time with people who've
done a lot more than us and by watching
their videos listen to them speak
hopefully some of their mindset their
values the way of thinking their
execution rubs off on to us to help us
become better versions of ourselves
so today we're going to learn from
former Indian president epj Abdul Kalam
and some of his inspirational speeches
as you watch the videos if he says
something that really inspires you or
means something to you make sure to put
it in the comments below and put quotes
around it so that others can be inspired
as well having you an instant this is
all of you who are assembled here all of
you remember this incident 1979 1979
slv-3 satellite launch vehicle I were
the project director mission director my
mission is to put the satellite in the
orbit thousands of people work nearly 10
years I reach the I reach the Surrey
arakata condition the launchpad counter
was going on
t-minus four minutes t-minus five
minutes t-minus one one minute t-minus
40 seconds computer put a hold don't
launch it computer says don't launch it
I am the mission director I have to take
decision everything is on behind me
there are six experts they saw did a
computer database coming in and screen
and they see the pictures of the screen
they said there's a problem the problem
is there's a leakage in a system in the
control system but immediately
calculation no problem
we have got sufficient fuel and oxidiser
country control system is contours a
rocket to the record attitude and we can
go ahead now of course my experts view
but I took a decision problems mine
right finally I took a decision i bypass
the computer I launch the system
inaudible event first state you worked
in a four stage rocket and second stage
got mad it went to the spinning instead
of putting the satellite in the orbit it
put in the way of the gun 1979 it was a
failure it was a failed first time I
experienced my failure how'd he manage
the failure success I can manage so at
that time be a great man you're a great
leader also Satish Dhawan he comes to me
I have very tired working nearly four
months it wakes me up come let us go for
a press conference
prosperous meeting there like this
number of people world press before all
this and that all the gadget they are
there I was really frightened I will be
the culprit because behind the project
that equation directly what's at least
our said chairman Indian speciality or
consent dear friends we have failed in
it
he is the first time I have to do all
the success all the failure is I want to
support my technologists and scientists
and staff so that next year they succeed
so he took the whole blame himself and
then media asked you put way of when got
so many crores you are putting like that
a lot of criticism he received a
criticism he assured them in a year will
succeed with our team is a very good
team next year
here only interesting they happened next
year July 18 1980 when he succeeded but
also now and said you go and conduct the
press conference do you follow with what
it means it means when the failure
occurred the leader took it up when the
success came he gives to his team you
should stand for a culture of excellence
the reaction is not by accident it is a
process where an individual
continuously strives to better oneself
the performance standards are set by
themselves they work on their dreams
with focus and are prepared to take
calculated risk and do not get deterred
by failures as they work towards their
dreams then this step of their dreams as
they tend to reach the original targets
they strive to work to their potential
in the process they increase their
performance there by multiplying further
their potential this is an onion ting
lifecycle phenomena culture of
excellence they are not in competition
with genuine arts but themselves that is
a culture of excellence I'm sure each
one of you will aspire to become a
unique with culture of excellence so
there was a break-in cyclist you are
travelling from London 1930 by ship to
Calcutta when he reached the Calcutta
angular that evenly around 6 o clock the
Sun was setting
at that time you looked at this time
first blue and she was blue the horizon
was blue but she sea water was blue he
asked a positive voice she's blue why
why horizons blue sky is blue of course
she has to work for two years hard work
in Calcutta then he got a Nobel Prize
for that because it was a back
scattering of light can you think of a
person
such severe Amon got the Nobel Prize for
that scattering of the light now we have
DCT very close to the city created a
very famous mathematician at that time
as a British India and the British India
could not locate him because he failed
the nth n plus 1 ten plus two in those
two he currently intermediate in every
subject except mathematics he could not
further go for higher education but
she's education something beyond his
bright genius he was a genius and
somebody you have British fall or
located this genius in port officer in
Madras and his papers are being sent to
Royal Society and professor Harding
sudden his paper then he waited in me
behemoth one of the greatest
mathematician of them security so this
is he was Ramanujan so friends there is
another great but greatly she's the
worry ladies got two Nobel Prize one for
radium discovering another for a physics
suffer material this lady is Madame
Curie and she lived for the radiation
she sacrificed life irradiation by
Furman because radiation therapy is she
tried on that and so friends all these
people see eight names are you you call
this eight names when I Delta Y event
what they are self without an
immediately when I say that the name of
the person you can relate the
reaction your foot one of him Thomas
Alva Edison immediately said bulb and
electricity
Alexander Graham Bell Telephone
immediately you said telephone telephone
I said Alexandra travel backscatter
infinite immediately sir such you round
radius radium immediately you can say
miracle so all these people they are
unique people is it not because they are
unique you are remembering so so far we
have studied those who walk into
unexplored paths and strive to be a
unique under remembered for their
contribution to the human type remember
period French inventions and discoveries
have emanated from creativeminds that
are being constantly working and making
the outcome in the mind with the imaging
and constantly effort all the forces of
the universe word for that despite mind
thereby leading to invention discoveries
I learned but carefully hear me what is
he I learned what did I learn from the
youth of 11 million people I learnt the
ovary youth wants to be unique every
youth wants to be unique that is you the
over you taught to be unique that is you
but the world around around you is doing
it test they might
you just need everybody else no no
questioning whether you want to be you
are everybody else you you want to be
you not your every else now if the first
being like everybody else is convenient
at the first glance but not satisfying
in the long vision the challenge there
for my young friends is that you have to
fight the hardest battle you have to
fight the hardest battle which any human
being can never imagine to fight and
never stop fighting until you arrive at
your destiny of you they've got to get
Negrete you it's a big battle the
battlements you don't need to take a
garden the battle means you have your
food unique things for unique tools you
must have that battle one is you have to
set the goal the second one is acquired
the knowledge continuously and third one
it's a hard work with the ocean and
fourties perseverance you gives up the
tools you have the other before the
battle the way you do these as we say in
India where there is righteousness in
the heart where there is righteousness
to the heart there is beauty in the
character when there is beauty in the
character there is harmony in the home
when there is harmony in the home there
is harmony where there is an order in
the nation when there is order in the
nation there is peace in the world
[Applause]
[Applause]
mr. president Abdul Kalam in the name of
the European Parliament I want to thank
you for this important and inspiring
speech this was one of the most
extraordinary speeches we have ever
heard from a statesman scientists and
poet this is unique all the best to this
great nation India all the best to our
cooperation between the great nation
India and the European Union all the
best mr. president thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed I'd
love to know which of the points
resonated most with you what are you
going to change in your life or your
business as a result of watching this
video leave it in the comments below
and I will join in the discussion
finally I want to give a quick shout out
to Evans Sargent I love your name Evan
by the way Evan thank you so much you're
buying a copy of my book it really means
a lot to me those you're watching you
want to change that a shadow in a future
video make sure to pick up a copy of the
book and email in your receipts so we
can keep track thank you guys so much
for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
where it is and I'll see you soon